les comptes du parti communiste pour
l'actualisation des mesures du programme
commun gaston defferre d'accord ou pas
d'accord gouvernement député de la meuse
et de la majorité cherche est un conte
premier à l'assemblée nationale la taxe
professionnelle un vrai casse tête s'est
décidée font fort à une grève générale
le 24
caen peut être le 24 avec la cgt la cfdt
et la fen s'il faut c'est enlever à
zuera
le délégué pour l'europe du front
polisario s'explique
mais là messieurs bonsoir nous vous le
laissions entendre hier soir c'est le 24
mai qu aura lieu cette grève générale
interprofessionnelle
annoncé au départ par la cgt la cfdt et
la fédération de l'éducation nationale
mais le deuxième élément nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que force ouvrière à
son tour lance un ordre de grève pour le
même jour la confédération d'andré
bergeron qui ouvrait aujourd'hui son
congrès annuel à vichy ne s'associera
pas aux manifestations de rue prévue le
24 mai mais a décidé quand même de
marquer le coup pour affirmer son
attachement à la liberté négociations
j'ai donc mandat de proposer au 13e
congrès de la cgt force ouvrière
d'appeler tous les salariés de ce pays a
observé une grève générale
interprofessionnelle de 24 heures pour
défendre la libye
déçu par l'échec de la politique
contractuelle poussé par une base de
plus en plus combative
un peu contre son gré force ouvrière se
jette donc dans la bataille cela n'était
pas arrivé depuis 1964 et andré bergeron
acclamé par les 2000 délégués de vichy
veut préserver son indépendance pas
question de l'unité d'action avec les
autres syndicats la journée du 24 n'est
pas une opération politique
nous avons des difficultés et nous
essayons par les moyens syndicaux
traditionnel de vaincre ses difficultés
mais après la grève
nous avons bien l'intention de retourner
voir monsieur barbe pour à nouveau
tenter de le convaincre du bon sens à
savoir de modifier l'attitude qui était
la sienne jusqu'à maintenant en vue de
permettre que nos organisations
parviennent à désaccord c'est un
comportement syndicale normal mais je
voudrais insister sur le fait que nous
ne sommes motivés par aucune
considération d'ordre politique ou
gouvernementales nous aurions la même
attitude avec un gouvernement de la
gauche
si la liberté de négociation était en
cause mais vis-à-vis des difficultés
actuelles de la vie prix francs 13,7
grâce du 24 mai quand même valeur de
symbole telle unité renouvelle sans
empêcher les gens de tirer les
conclusions
moi je dis ce qui est dans notre esprit
nous avons jugé nécessaire de faire
cette action parce que nous voulons
défendre la liberté de négociation mais
tout ce qu'on pourra dire autour ne
repose pas sur la réalité à savoir si le
poids personnel de monsieur bergeron est
encore suffisant aujourd'hui pour
renouer le dialogue avec le gouvernement
monsieur bah oui la cfdt et la cgt ont
aussitôt applaudie à l'initiative
d'andré bergeron ce sera une grande
journée a dit georges séguy lui n'est
s'associe au mouvement et la cgc
décidera samedi de sa position de même
d'ailleurs que la cftc va donc un écueil
supplémentaire sur la route de raymond
barre qui ce matin avait dû faire face à
nouveau à la fronde des députés de la
majorité
il s'agit cette fois du texte
gouvernemental sur la taxe
professionnelle
mais plutôt que de provoquer un th de
nouvelles tensions entre matignon le rpr
le ministre robert boulin à négocier en
douceur il a demandé au gouvernement de
retirer son projet de loi et de leur
présenter à mende et demain alors daniel
brême donc la guerre de la taxe
professionnelle n'aura pas lieu
il a fait re soulevées par cette affaire
la semaine dernière a fondu comme neige
au soleil
monsieur boulin s'est multiplié sur tous
les fronts de petits déjeuners en
déjeuner de réunion regroupant réunion
deux présidents avocat dans le civil il
a négocié toute la journée avec le rpr
les réformateurs et les républicains
indépendants un accord sur un texte de
compromis
on n'avait pas vu depuis longtemps dans
le couloir monsieur gino le jeune et
l'abbé la main dans la main et la
majorité aussi unanime et monsieur
boulet a même trouvé un coupable pour le
mauvais calcul de la répartition de ces
textes c'est l'ordinateur qui n'est pas
intelligent elle fait sur boule un
conciliateur jusqu'au bout a aussi fait
observer que la formule retenue pourrait
être revu d'ici deux ans avec l'ensemble
de la fiscalité locale brême quand est
ce que les députés vont ils se prononcer
et bien mardi prochain à 16h sur un
texte qui ne laisse ni vainqueur ni
vaincu et qui a considérablement assaini
et détendu l'atmosphère
d'ailleurs ce même jour raymond barre
dans une interview publiée par le
journal
elle affirmait que le gouvernement
ne laisserait pas à grignoter son
autorité n'acceptera pas la mise en
liberté surveillée dont on a parlé de
françois mitterrand chacun prendra ses
responsabilités a ajouté raymond barre
en faisant visiblement allusion au rpr
mais revenons au texte proprement dit la
taxe professionnelle vous devez
commencer à le savoir depuis le temps
que le projet est en gestation
c'est une taxe destinée à remplacer
l'ancien patente
alors voyons ce que le gouvernement
propose pour remédier aux inconvénients
d'un impôt ca populaire la patente trop
impopulaire a été supprimée en 1975 pour
un autre impôt la taxe professionnelle
destiné lui aussi approvisionner les
caisses des collectivités locales ce
devait être un impôt plus juste plus
moderne plus simple calculé sur une
partie des salaires versés par les
entreprises et sur la valeur locative
des murs et des équipements la taxe
professionnelle devait être surtout un
impôt moins lourd pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises mais ô surprise
pour une entreprise sur quatre les plus
grosses la facture était souvent
multiplié par 2 3 4 5 ou 7
du coup la protestation s'est organisée
chambre de commerce et cnpf en tête et
le gouvernement dû faire machine arrière
en décidant candia 176 le relèvement de
l'impôt payé au titre de la taxe
professionnelle ne pourrait pas excéder
170% de l'ex patente
deux jours avant le débat mitterrand
barre les communistes viennent de mettre
un chiffre en phase du programme commun
près de 500 milliards de francs de
dépenses globales d'ici à 1980 c'est ce
que révèle ce matin l'humanité un
chiffre qui paraît assez gros en tout
cas lourd à supporter pour les
entreprises près de 350 milliards de
francs mais détaillons ces chiffres
combien de fois n'at-on pas répliquer
aux propositions économiques du parti
communiste combien ça coûtera qui paiera
aujourd'hui il le dit et il imprime dans
l'humanité de ce matin
d'abord le niveau de vie des français le
smic passera 2200 francs
le pouvoir d'achat moyen des salaires
augmenterait de 10 % le minimum
yes serait portée à 1200 francs les
allocations familiales seraient
revalorisés coûte 313 milliards de
francs un peu plus que le budget de
l'état en 1977
qui paierait les entreprises elle
supporterait l'essentiel de
l'augmentation des salaires et des
cotisations sociales pour l'état et les
collectivités locales
la facture serait de 149 milliards de
francs le parti communiste se donne
d'ici à 1982 pour revenir à une
situation de plein emploi pour le pc
deux conditions nationaliser les
entreprises déjà désigné et revenir à
une croissance de 6% l'an 1500 milliards
de francs gaston defferre c'est une
facture énorme le pc vous un petit peu
mis devant le fait accompli
certains parlent de peaux de banane le
parti communiste a publié les chiffres
qui ne sont pas ceux du programme commun
qui sont les chiffres des propositions
communistes
une fois que commentaires sur ce chiffre
françois mitterrand après demain d'avoir
des pas très importants avec monsieur
bart qu'il appréciera s'il doit traiter
ce sujet et comment qui doit traiter
est ce à dire que vous avez d'autres
chiffres non je ne vous dis simplement
je crois que je vais dans la ville
puisse appeler de dire sur telles
qu'elles sont je ne veux pas parler de
sujets ce sujet ce soir je considère que
je n'ai pas en parler six prochains mois
estime devoir le faire
jeudi il le fera mais lors il ya un
programme commun mais des chiffres qui
eux sont particuliers nous sommes dans
une période qui est là ce qu'on appelle
la période réévaluation de
l'appréciation du programme commun
chacun veut avoir dans cette période
préparatoire à château nombre d'idées
avant siens se nomme deux chiffres quand
nous nous serons réunis
c'est mardi prochain à cowes et réunions
vous le savez nous serons amenés à
discuter et décider comme nous l'avons
fait en 1972 d'ici là les positions
prises par les uns et par les autres
n'engagent que ceux qui les prennent il
n'aurait pas mieux valu à
andres quand même cette négociation
avant de publier des chiffres ou au
moins vous prévenir de la publication
vous les avez appris dans l'humanité
vous savez les partis politiques ont
chacun leur autonomie regarder ce qui se
passe dans la majorité
tout à l'air j'écoutais daniel brême
elle présentait la fin de la journée
mais c'est vous avez vous avez présenté
ce qui s'est passé dans le courant de la
journée
vous auriez vu les partis de la majorité
s'affronter comme ils se sont affrontés
il ya quelques temps quand monsieur bart
engager sa responsabilité devant
l'assemblée nationale
ils se sont quasiment insulté alors nous
ce n'est pas du tout le cas nous chacun
de nous
avant la rencontre on peut présenter à
ce nombre de documents et puis ensemble
nous travaillerons et comme nous le
faisons d'habitude j'en suis convaincu
nous nous mettrons d'accord qui attend
le faire sans parler de chiffres est ce
que vous croyez qu'il y à autant de
gâchis dans l'économie française que
connolly parti communiste vous êtes vous
même un chef d'entreprise
oui je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup
effectivement et pense que les choses
pourraient aller beaucoup mieux
je constate en tout cas que ce
gouvernement à la tête de l'acte duquel
il y à nous du temps le meilleur
économiste de france n'a pas réussi ni
dans le domaine du chômage ni dans le
domaine de l'inflation ni dans le
domaine de l' équilibre budgétaire
rappelez vous monsieur bart avait
annoncé qu'il n'y aurait pas de déficit
il ya déjà 10 milliards ni dans le
domaine du commerce extérieur alors vous
savez n'ont pas beaucoup de leçons à
recevoir s'est résorbé le chômage il
faudrait combien de temps peut réserver
le chômage il faudra un certain temps ça
dépendra bien entendu de mesures qui
seront prises
c'est telles mesures peuvent avoir un
effet immédiat dans le domaine des
travaux publics et de la construction
par exemple si on débloque les crédits
si à nous par exemple municipalité on
nous accorde des subventions et en os
permet d'emprunter pour très vite
l'ancien de grands projets et par
conséquent accélérer la reprise
dernière question gaston defferre vous
parliez des difficultés de la majorité
parlons du petit problème au sein du ps
vous voulez
réduire le crs au silence et non quand
il joue le parti socialiste est un parti
démocratique dans lequel chacun
s'exprime librement
il y à des courants de pensée ya le
courant numéro un il a cru en numéro 2
nous proposons la démocratie et la
france nous en donnant l'image nouvelle
dans le passé au congrès de grenoble
la synthèse s'est faite au cours du
congrès au congrès de pau sa thèse de
s'est pas faite et de crs continuer à
exister à nantes à sa thèse se fera
peut-être ne sera-t-il pas je n'en sais
rien ce qui est important c'est que
chacun puisse s'exprimer librement
on vous retrouve un ans mercy gaston
defferre l'étranger au moment même où
s'achève la visite officielle du
ministre robert galley en mauritanie
antenne 2 est en mesure de diffuser une
interview exclusive
celle de l'un des dirigeants du front
polisario qui ont enlevés il ya une
semaine six français au sahara dans cet
entretien recueillies anonymement pour
des raisons de sécurité par bernard
benyamin le polisario va plus loin
nous aurions pu les tuer dit il et nous
pourrions commencer nous nous sommes
attaqués à surat fortifications qui
constitue actuellement une base de
départ d'agression puisqu'ils s'y
trouvent d'importantes concentrations de
troupes maroco mauritanienne qui pète le
génocide est le crime contre notre pays
contre notre peuple
mais j'avais d'envié là un objectif
militaire et économique
donc il y avait des civils également un
sourire at il y avait des français
vous le saviez absolument il y en a deux
qui sont morts six autres qui sont
portées disparues azuré que nous avons
épargner les civils
et si nous avons voulu leur faire du mal
on aurait pu le faire ce que nous avons
évité à tout prix alors c'est six
français qui sont disparus
on se préoccupe du sort de français mais
c'est ton préoccupé jusqu'à présent du
sort de tout un peuple chassé de chez
lui victime d'un génocide agressé par le
maroc et la mauritanie
aqua j'ajoute nous avons réitéré à
maintes reprises d avertissement à
l'intention des étrangers des intérêts
étrangers dans des zones de guerre leur
avons demandé que ni le maroc ni la
mauritanie ne sont pas à même de
garantir les intérêts étrangers et moins
encore la sécurité de leurs
ressortissants étrangers est ce que ça
veut dire que jouer raté la première
d'une série d' attaques contre des
positions françaises au maroc en
mauritanie nous nous attaquons au maroc
et à la mauritanie qui monte agression
notre pays et nous pouvons dire que tous
les internautes que tout ce qui a trait
à l'agression contre le peuple sahraoui
ne pourrait être que combattu parce
qu'ici ça veut dire que vous allez
recommencer
cela veut dire que nous allons continuer
notre combat mais que nous avons
l'intention d'agresser personne n'a
touché personne est là toute une série
de télégrammes étrangers très
significatif d'abord le retour en
espagne de celle que l'on appelle la
pasionaria de l'aurès ibarruri une
vieille dame de 82 ans maintenant en
exil depuis 40 ans à moscou madrid vient
de lui permettre de rentrer elle
reviendrait en espagne peut-être à la
fin de la semaine
l'arrestation du révérend paisley s'il a
des chefs des extrémistes protestants de
l'irlande du nord
il avait été interpellé sur une
barricade et on l'a relâché dans la
journée
le démenti de l'ol péché l'organisation
de libération de la palestine nous ne
sommes pas prêts à reconnaître
l'existence de l'état d'israël tout cela
est prématuré et puis la libération de
l'écrivain contestataires romain paul
goma et puis londres toujours londres
toujours lé sommet les chefs d'état de
gouvernement n'en finissent pas de se
voir et de se revoir nous en sommes
aujourd'hui au conseil de l'otan'' avec
toujours envie d'être américain jimmy
carter la france elle n'est représentée
que par son ministre des affaires
rangèrent au menu des travaux de l'otan
une meilleure coordination des
différents pays en matière d'armement
mais sans que cela se traduise par une
suprématie mais c'est le 4 avril 1949
que le traité de l'atlantique nord a été
signé à washington
aujourd'hui quinze nations font donc
partie de l'otan la france fait partie
de l'otan
mais depuis le 10 mars 1966 elle s'est
retiré de l'organisation militaire c'est
pourquoi ici à norfolk où se trouve le
commandement en chef de la marine
le drapeau français est absent au moment
de la levée des couleurs des pays de
l'otan
les ici via une liaison militaire
française dont on ne verra pas les
officiers pendant notre visite relations
cordiales mes strips donc entre
américains et français
car ceux ci rejette la tutelle des
premiers relation pas très facile avec
les autres alliés l'angleterre par
exemple
cet avion est anglais qui s'appelle le
rire et il illustre bien la
collaboration entre les deux frères
anglo saxons mais aujourd'hui au mois de
mai 1977
les anglais sont confrontés au problème
aw l'avion américain wax qui sera prêt
en 1980 est un avion radar avec 17
radars de contrôle
les anglais veulent faire leur propre à
un moment parce que nous voulons éviter
un problème de chômage dans notre usine
de munitions mais techniquement et
technologiquement peut-être nous serons
pas capables
ainsi nous allons créer des avions comme
les avions ni mode qui sont pas aussi
bons que les avions américains 27
appareils et le système awacs ont été
adoptées par les ministres de la défense
de l'otan mais des onglets vont
construire l'avion nimrod
c'est un avion radar mais utilisable
seulement sur ma mère les américains
vont construire à un avion qui est
beaucoup plus meyer qui est utilisable
sur mer et sur terre alors l'avion
américain c'est logique il faut acheter
l'avion américain
mais comme un mythe mon les anglais
l'ont obligé à construire quand même
l'avion inférieur
on saura au mois de juillet si
l'angleterre est décidé à acheter des
avions awacs ou si elle fait cavalier
seul ce qui ne manquerait pas de
compliquer l'harmonisation européenne
sur le plan militaire ce que les experts
appellent la standardisation dont on
trouve une illustration avec le char
allemand roland 2 le grand problème qui
se pose à l'otan à ce moment là c'est là
le problème de la standardisation
si vous avez division de l'armée de la
bundeswehr d'un côté une division
américaine en ce moment même les change
de certains partis vital est à carrer
impossible
les dernières discussions entre les deux
ministres la défense on venait quand
même certains accords en général et on
s'est arrangé en principe que certaines
parties soit arrachant diable voir le
canon principal et les chaînes du char
se seraient déjà grand chose la
tentation américaine est donc fort
d'imposer à ses alliés du matériel mais
d'ignorer c'est comme le fameux f 16
malgré ces pressions l'otan est appelé à
élargir son alliance avec demain
peut-être l'espagne bat restons dans
l'aviation l'airbus retrouve du tonus de
bonnes nouvelles coup sur coup
aujourd'hui d'avoir cette déclaration du
président de la compagnie américaine
east airlines
si nous sommes contents de notre
location d'airbus nous pourrions en
acheter plus de 50
et puis cette information qui nous vient
du japon où l'airbus pourraient être
vendus là bas aussi
c'est demain que la france accueille le
premier ministre canadien pierre elliott
trudeau un mélange de séjour privé de
visites officielles ponctuée par un
déjeuner vendredi avec valéry giscard
d'estaing n'est pas très difficile
d'imaginer que le problème du québec
sera au programme des conversations
entre les deux hommes sont en effet une
épine dans le pied du gouvernement
fédéral canadien depuis novembre depuis
que les élections au québec ont amené au
pouvoir une large majorité favorables
sinon l'indépendance du moins à une
large autonomie
mais le mouvement est amorcé depuis bien
plus longtemps que cela
tout avait commencé il ya dix sept ans
avec une chanson
en pays les gens ce rêve
et ce grand pas
mon pays candy du tram
tu n'entends rien
au québec tout a commencé par la chance
en 1967 homme claude léveillée a pris
les armes
ses armes et a déclenché ce qu'on
appelle ici la révolution tranquille
la victoire aux élections du 15 novembre
dernier du parti québécois qui veut
séparer le québec du canada n'est qu'une
étape de plus dans la longue prise de
conscience d'un peuple à la recherche
d'une patrie cette patrie que chante
léveillé
c'est la chanson qui arrivait ce petit
matériaux que vous servez vous en france
comme étant une chose on saisit parfois
et souvent à m pour lui devenir une arme
très importante reçoit ça ça débloque et
ça ça provoque et nous seulement la
nation le peuple québécois mais ça a
provoqué aussi tous les temps d'argent
aux québécois tout ce qu'avait dit
pouvoir de faire quelque chose exemple
et ce n'est que plus tard la caisse dans
mon dernier cov qu'on puisse leur
lacanau sa poigne espèce de journée qui
s'annonce important pour le québec
on y lit bec premier ministre chef du
parti québécois il veut donner au québec
une véritable souveraineté en
bouleversant le système fédéral canadien
pour les canadiens anglais il veut
détruire le canada est évident que si on
réussit on va détruire une certaine
forme institutionnelle en partie en tout
cas en ce qui concerne le québec du
canada tel qu'il existe et ça ça veut
pas dire de détruire la réalité
canadienne ça pourrait au contraire être
un stimulant qui lui permettrait dans
une nouveau contexte une nouvelle forme
d'association entre le québec et le
canada qui permettrait au canada lui
aussi d'avoir un avenir beaucoup plus
stable est beaucoup plus prometteur
le quartier saint-henri à montréal ici
on parle français
ici on n'est pas bien riche ici on a
voté massivement pour rené lévesque
mais la politique c'était en novembre
dernier
ce printemps ce qui soulève les passions
à saint-henri surtout chez les jeunes
c'est le hockey traditionnellement la
seule façon pour un canadien français de
réussir à l'échelle de tout le continent
nord américain
c'était c'est encore bloc cette équipe
les canadiens de montréal est la
meilleure du tout la ligue
professionnelle nord américaine sans
doute la meilleure du mur quand les
canadiens gagnent c'est une victoire du
québec tout entier à travers les
canadiens sur la glace à travers rené
lévesque en politique c'est tout le
québec qui prend sa revanche pour les
anglophobes il dépend exemple que nos
compatriotes des langues anglais soit
sur la terrasse parce qu'ils sont
nerveux distances sont très nerveuses
ont peur se réveille faux faux faux pas
les endormir en disant ben écoutez ça
soit pas si grave que ça non vous savez
moi j'ai toujours considéré le québécois
est ce assez constant dans notre
histoire à l'occuper point je pense que
c'est beaucoup une américaine qui
parlent français parce que même si j'ai
souvent france même si plusieurs des
nôtres nous allons en france même chose
sans billet chez vous on sent qu'on
n'est pas des fractions du palais
européenne nous avons je passe une
perception american pie
cette perception différente vient de
l'histoire les paysans normand poitevin
bretons qui sont arrivés ici en 16 140
ont dû s'adapter à une terre un climat à
une nature qui leur était inconnu un
exemple les rave dont la feuille est
devenu l'emblème du canada chaque année
guy lefebvre agriculteur à saint benoît
vient dans la forêt entaillé le tronc
des érables qu'on recueillir la serre
après évaporation ce jus fournira du
sirop d'érable et du sucre d'érable ce
qui était pour les premiers québécois la
seule source de sucre est devenu une
tradition mais aussi un rite quand la
serre foule des érables c'est que
l'hiver se termine un rythme auquel
participent tous les québécois
chaque week-end des citadins se pressent
dans des cabanes à sucre bord des routes
pour manger du jambon arrosé de sirop
d'érable d'avoir du jus d'érable pour
danser chaque année les québécois fait
ainsi la fin d'hiver mais en ce
printemps 1977
on fait aussi la fin d'une nuit
politique qui a duré deux siècles et la
naissance d'un nouveau québec
mon pays candidats
tu n'entends rien
alors si tu dis là est éveillé de jeunes
chanteurs rock du chanteur acquitté des
finances américaines l'angleterre est ce
que je fais vient partir de racines très
profondes qui s'appelle le pays afin
une information tout à fait surprenante
à vous donner mertens n'a pas gagné
l'étape d'aujourd'hui dans le tour
d'espagne c'est l'espagnol melero qu'il
a remporté le belge conserve tout de
même son maillot de leader peut être at
il été troublé par les sanctions qui
viennent de pleuvoir sur les cyclistes
belges par suite de dopage un mois de
suspension pour eddy merckx trois mois
de suspension avec sursis pour mehr tête
en automobile c'est une journée presque
historique qu'ont vécu les sportifs
français ils ont en effet découvert une
voiture tricolore pourra bientôt en
formule 1
une voiture pour la première fois
construite par ce qu'on appelle un
constructeur classique c'est-à-dire une
usine qui fait aussi bien des voitures
de tous les jours je veux parler de run
enfant caché du sport automobile depuis
trois ans la formule 1 était présentée
par sa mère la régie renault se met
vêtue d'un ensemble jaune qui souligne
parfaitement sa ligne la dernière née de
la régie est séduit par son charme ses
mensurations empattement de médecins qu
largeur arrière à mettre 5 125 x 600 kg
ce bébé éprouvette revêt sur le plan
technique une particularité son moteur
est un 15 centimètres cubes 6 cylindres
en v équipée d'un turbo compresseur
développant 500 chevaux
la renault est la seule formule 1 qui
utilisent ce système cp diab pardon ses
mécaniciens qui la suivent depuis sa
naissance estime que ce moteur permettra
à leurs apprentis championne de réaliser
rapidement d'excellentes performances de
nombreux pilotes qui ont bien sûr fait
la cour et son cutter gérard larrousse
accordé son volant à jean pierre
jabouille première sortie officielle du
couple
théoriquement le grand prix de france
début juillet auparavant la renault sera
testé sur le circuit de jarama où vient
de se dérouler le grand prix d'espagne
afin de comparer ses performances à
celles des autres formule 1 la même
opération sera renouvelée après le grand
prix de belgique à zolder
cette nouvelle sur laquelle aucun
commentaire une femme de 52 ans que l'on
accusé d'avoir laissé mourir de faim son
fils débile mental a été cet après-midi
acquitté par la cour d'assises de l'oise
le temps pour terminer il n'est pas prêt
de se remettre au printemps le ciel sera
couvert demain sur toute la moitié nord
température sans grand changement sur la
moitié sud
il y aura davantage d'éclaircies avec
une hausse des températures je ne peux
terminer tout à fait sans vous apprends
un grand monsieur a quitté ce matin le
territoire français ramsès 2 est reparti
pour le caire ça faisait sept mois qu'il
se reposait se soigner à paris et c'est
alice saunier séité qui l'avait
accueilli en france qui l'a raccompagné
très poliment ce matin au bourget bon
voyage dernier rendez-vous avec
l'actualité
betty d'euros après les dossiers de
l'écran vers 23h30
bonsoir à tous à demain